Buonasera
molto spesso
le domande sono molto più importanti che
le risposte che possiamo trovare cercare
qualche mese fa per essere preciso il 13
di agosto scorso
ho avuto un'esperienza che mi ha colpito
mi ha scosso mi ha fatto pormi delle
domande
e Volevo cominciare oggi con qualcosa di
personale e questo è stato un momento
che veramente mi ha fatto riflettere
profondamente No era una giornata come
un'altra stavo scendendo da casa mia a
me un po' in mezzo al bosco andando
verso il tempio per guidare una sezione
di meditazione e ho avuto un insolito
incontro con un insetto Non ho mai
capito ancora quale Fatto sta che è
entrato fra gli occhiali e gli occhi e
Facendo un riassunto son finito con uno
shock anafilattico
ho perso coscienza Grazie mille c'era
vicino sono riuscito a comunicare con
un'amica medico che è riuscita ad
aiutarmi in quel momento Poi è arrivata
l'ambulanza tutto il resto
e quando ha ripreso coscienza stavo bene
però stato dopo quando parlavo con
l'amica medico e con altri medici con
cui ho parlato che mi hanno detto amato
hai capito cosa ti è successo
io non avevo capito del tutto E lì ho
sentito una forte un forte senso di aver
ricevuto diciamo così una benedizione
qualcosa che secondo me estremamente
importante di cui avevo parlato diverse
volte ma quella volta ho avuto una
esperienza diretta che è la preziosità
di sperimentare il quanto Ogni giorno
della nostra vita sia varioso e sia
prezioso
perché c'è qualcosa che è normale che è
naturale anche se facciamo un po' finta
di niente che il fatto che siamo nati
siamo qui E inevitabilmente prima o poi
moriremo No siamo d'accordo no
e non c'è nulla di male Non c'è nulla di
sbagliato Non c'è niente di male in
morire
il vero problema è vivere male
e molto spesso noi passiamo la nostra
vita presi con tantissime piccole cose
che cerchiamo di risolvere nella nostra
vita di tutti i giorni piccoli problemi
da risolvere questo mi piace quello non
mi piace passiamo la vita un po' come
dicevo un maestro dell'undicesimo secolo
in Tibet che si chiamava t-shirt che
diceva di giorno siamo distratti di
notte dormiamo
e la vita passa
ok
abbiamo fatto
siamo distratti su tante cose
siamo distratti ancora nei tempi in cui
viviamo ancora di più da una quantità di
stimoli sensoriali spaventosa che
portano tanti effetti nella nostra vita
fra cui più Anse eccetera eccetera Ma
fatto sta che spesso non ci chiediamo
dove sto andando cosa voglio fare dove
voglio andare cosa voglio diventare
e una volta parlavo con un amico anni fa
e gli ho chiesto Matte Ti piace la
meditazione e mi disse Sì sì mi piace
tantissimo e quando medito al mattino
sto bene per tutto il giorno
ha detto Che bello Quindi mediti tutti i
giorni no E lui mi disse
sono da tre mesi che non merito Io mi
sono chiesto Ma perché ci sono delle
cose che noi sappiamo che ci fanno bene
e comunque noi non li facciamo
e riflettendo su questo così come ci
sono quelle cose che noi sappiamo che ci
fanno male e comunque li continuiamo a
fare
però riflettendo sulla prima domanda
perché ci sono delle cose che sappiamo
che ci fanno bene alla fine non
riusciamo a farli non li facciamo mi
sono trovato un giorno dinanzi a una
frase di una poesia di un maestro che si
chiamava
il sesto Dalai Lama Ricordiamoci che il
sesto Dalai Lama diversamente di solito
Lama in Tibet e così via lui ha
rifiutato totalmente avere qualunque
potere politico in quanto Dalai Lama di
quella è anche non voleva assolutamente
seguire la vita monastica
era conosciuto per tutte le sue
fidanzate in giro e ed è rimasto nella
storia come un grande poeta d'amore
e in una delle due delle sue poesie Lui
scrisse una frase che mi colpì e mi
aiuto molto a cercare una risposta
trovare una risposta più che altro E lui
disse in una poesia verso una donna in
specifico in un'altra poesia verso le
donne in generale E lui disse Se io
desiderassi
l'illuminazione tanto quanto desidero le
donne sarei già illuminato
no
perché aveva ragione
perché la realtà è che noi non facciamo
quello che noi non vogliamo
è una delle forze più potenti che esiste
nella nostra vita è il desiderio magari
qualcuno avrà sentito dire che nel
Buddismo il desiderio è qualcosa che va
eliminato
mi è questa è una parola che mi piace
tanto che c'è solo in italiano almeno no
Fatto sta che il desiderio Dipende cosa
intendiamo per desiderio
proiettare la nostra felicità su
qualcosa che non riesce veramente a
sostenerla è una fregatura e va evitato
però nella vita non si fa nulla se non
c'è desiderio di solito si usa nel
contesto più virtuoso la parola
aspirazione Però in fondo è una forma di
desiderio e cosa voglio perché quando
c'è passione verso qualcosa non andiamo
a misurare gli sforzi e dire no è
difficile no facciamo tutto il possibile
una volta stavo parlando di questo
proprio e c'era ho fatto la domanda
quando siamo innamorati di qualcuno di
qualcosa no c'è chi si innamora di una
persona C'è chi si innamora di un
progetto C'è chi si innamora di se
stesso anche quello può succedere
ma quando siamo innamorati quanto spesso
pensiamo
nell'oggetto del nostro innamoramento
e fece questa domanda c'era una ragazza
che era lì nella sala ed era
estremamente innamorata in quel periodo
e le disse una volta che non finisce mai
ed è vero quando c'è passione quando c'è
desiderio verso qualcosa
la nostra mente è fortemente direzionata
ai nostri pensieri le nostre azioni in
qualunque momento giorno e notte andiamo
verso quello
Io sono convinto che una delle cose più
importanti di cui tutti noi abbiamo
bisogno e di aver passione
ed innamorarci di qualcosa di bello di
virtuoso di positivo nella nostra vita e
quindi quando ho avuto quella mia
esperienza
di
svegliarmi e vedere la faccia spaventata
spaventata del Canada questa amica
medico olandese che mi sono più
spaventato e la faccia sua che mi vedeva
che mi teneva abbracciato da dietro che
tenendo il polso che non lo sentiva più
mi guardo io mi sono chiesto dopo ma io
cosa voglio
ma veramente che cosa sto facendo Dove
sto andando ma io cosa voglio nella mia
vita più di tutto
ed è una domanda che tutti ce la
dobbiamo fare
e non so per quale ragione la volta che
ho trovato la risposta più chiara che
quello che cerco ancora di seguire che
voleva un po' condividere con voi perché
è importante chiederci Che cosa vogliono
nella vita
non prendere questo per scontato non
lasciare la vita che si svolge un giorno
dopo l'altro e tanto si vive e prima o
poi finisce no
dobbiamo darci una direzione
e io ho dato una direzione importante
per me che ancora oggi seguo proprio la
prima volta che sono venuto a Verbania
Non so perché quel momento eh ero in
macchina a quell'epoca vivevo in India
era intorno nel 99 e c'era guidava
Francesco con Gabriela era di notte
pioveva e Francesco di sè ti faccio fare
lungo l'ago Io stavo lì pensando ma a
lungo lago non si vede niente piove pure
e sono stanco ho fatto lungo viaggio per
dire È stato uno dei momenti più
importanti per me e non è che è accaduto
che ne so nelle montagne del Tibet in
mezzo al monastero di Taci lompo luogo
mistico qualcosa ne è successo a lungo
lago di Verbania mentre pioveva e
pensavo a tutt'altro Ah non è che era un
momento così particolare di inspirazione
te l'ho fatto sta che mentre ero lì ho
avuto questo pensiero che mi ha colpito
fortemente profondamente
problemi esistono ed esisteranno sempre
e mi sono detto che bello
Che bello
perché anche qual è la regola finisce un
problema
ne comincia un altro E cosa succede
quando c'è l'eccezione finisce un
problema e non cominci un altro lo
creiamo noi
Questo è quello che succede di solito
io ho detto che bello perché fino a quel
giorno Io ho messo mi ero accorto in
quel momento mi sono accorto in quel
momento che fino a quel giorno io vivevo
la vita cercando di creare una realtà
idealizzata intorno a me
io volevo risolvere i problemi con
voglio ancora
però volevo proiettavo che la mia
felicità nel fatto che il giorno che
questo andrà a posto e quell'altro andrà
a posto e quell'altro sarà così andrà
tutto bene E cosa succede quando arriva
quel giorno c'è qualcos'altro che non va
e quindi da questo mi sono detto ma io
veramente cosa voglio
io voglio essere in armonia in pace
Voglio stare bene con me stesso e con il
mondo che mi circonda con le persone con
cui mi trovo con le situazioni in cui
sono indipendentemente
di dove sono con chi sono o in quale
situazione mi trovo
perché se il mio stato di pace di
felicità di benessere deve dipendere
dal contesto in cui mi trovo sono
fregato perché problemi ci sono e ci
saranno sempre io sono sicuro di tutti
noi che siamo oggi qui c'è qualcuno che
non ha dei problemi
dobbiamo fare la competizione di chi ha
più problemi riusciamo a competere bene
Secondo me ci ne abbiamo tutti
però il punto non è questo Perché man
mano che ci sono i problemi vengono
delle soluzioni e la vita passa è una
cosa comincia poi finisce Poi c'è
un'altra e quando abbiamo visto il tempo
passa Però noi continuiamo
e qui io mi pongo una domanda che
condivido anche pongo anche a voi
Condivido anche con voi questa domanda
ci sono due forze che ci guidano nella
nostra vita Due forze motrici nella
nostra vita
il passato
in cui noi nel momento presente andiamo
ad agire a reagire a secondo di ciò che
è accaduto
o vicino lontano
e l'altra forza motrice importante il
solito non tanto riconosciuta e il
futuro
e dove io vivo il presente non come un
semplice risultato del passato ma come
la causa del futuro
ed è qui che ci chiediamo io chi voglio
essere
ed il problema più grande che io trovo e
mi ricordo una volta che ero in un
monastero in Tibet Ero andato lì per
studiare e a un certo punto mi hanno
chiesto di andare a dare una lezione in
questo monastero che si chiama gnemon
ghiacci e io ho chiesto Ma una lezione
da me
Ma fino adesso sì sì perché tu sei
discepolo di ramagangen e quindi ho
detto sono andato lì e mentre ero con
loro mi sono accorto che il vero
problema anche loro li
e sapere veramente cosa vogliamo e
credere che noi ce la possiamo fare e
aver fiducia in noi stessi
però chiedersi dove voglio andare
e non rimanere semplicemente nella
nostra
semplice quotidianità con le cose
eccetera non basta risolvere i problemi
non basta avere dei piaceri va bene i
problemi esistono per essere risolti
piacere esistono per essere goduti sono
d'accordo niente di male però ci poniamo
la domanda oltre questo dove voglio
andare chi voglio essere
Io vi invito a riflettere su questo
Ricordiamoci che se io voglio vivere in
armonia con me stesso e con gli altri
io devo imparare a farlo oggi
quando noi ci siamo davanti a un'altra
persona con cui abbiamo un rapporto può
essere familiare di coppia di lavoro io
mi chiedo che tipo di rapporto vuole
avere con te Voglio avere un rapporto
basato sull'amore sulla fiducia sul
rispetto sulla gratitudine sulla
consapevolezza o voglio avere un
rapporto basato sulla sfiducia sul
conflitto sulla rabbia sulla arroganza e
così via
se io vi chiedessi che tipo di rapporto
volete avere con le persone che
conoscete Immagino che volete il primo
no
adesso immaginiamo una persona qualunque
pensate voi a qualcuno io c'ho qualcuno
in mente
un bel giorno va Tutto bene con la
persona a un certo punto succede che
l'altra persona per qualunque ragione
del mondo sia
agisce verso di noi con aggressività ci
parla in un modo scortese ci parla con
aggressività eccetera qual è il nostro
modo di agire verso l'altro quando
l'altro agisce verso di noi con
aggressività
lo stesso
però proprio lì che io mi devo chiedere
ma che tipo di rapporto voglio avere con
te un rapporto Pacifico rispettoso
amorevole paziente centra un rapporto
conflittuoso e così via io voglio avere
un rapporto di rispetto di amore perciò
io voglio relazionarmi con te in questo
modo per costruire questo rapporto nel
futuro
come voglio avere la mia salute nel
futuro vuole avere un corpo sano devo
vivere sano oggi
perciò Ricordiamoci che nel momento
presente Esiste un potere enorme
ogni azione che compiamo ha un potere
enorme di trasformare e modellare e
costruire la nostra vita
noi abbiamo questa capacità però la
realtà si trova in ogni giorno il potere
reale si trova in ogni azione in ogni
cosa che pensiamo in ogni parola che
diciamo
è inevitabilmente volendo o no Noi
stiamo sempre costantemente in
trasformazione perciò io vi invito a
riflettere e chiedervi In che direzione
volete trasformarvi e Ricordiamoci che
le possibilità il potere anche per stare
in pace con noi e con gli altri e
conseguentemente essere un tasselino per
la pace nella società in cui viviamo
perché come la maganger ci ricordava
spesso la pace interiore e il fondamento
più solido per la pace nel mondo e se
vogliamo la pace come Essa da noi con
noi stessi e con quelli con cui viviamo
Grazie mille
[Applauso]